I'm very excited I know I'm very I'm
excited I'm so excited you look so
handsome in your suit I love it
um I understand that we both have
ranches so where's yours
I I won't tell you okay it's in the
vicinity it's in the vicinity our
inventor accounting so oh in California
yes mine's in Montana yeah I didn't be
like what's
Association Yes mine is in Montana yeah
that was yours in California since the
end of Magnum yeah and I love it yeah
yeah do you personally work the ranch
yeah well that's look that's what I do
for fun I work it's awesome yeah I mean
I uh
um
oak trees and I have planted a lot of
native Oaks I'm we're we're pretty green
at my place we're on well water we don't
have any City Water yeah and
and I have this whole family of trees
um because I've been there
oh 25 years I don't know so gross I have
I have little babies that I just planted
and yeah teenagers and uh now I got some
grown-up trees I love that though
awesome girl you it takes forever to
watch them grow so it's awesome like
when you planted them now they're still
don't see it I know that's awesome you
can see the little bits of growth I
think that's really cool
um so what you also have grandchildren
you enjoy I do have grandchildren and
and uh
um I love them dearly yeah um are they
crazy are they all over the place
they're no they're all centrally located
near the ranch so I I get to see them oh
that's cool as often as as I'd like with
the Cobin yeah we were under
as you were I'm sure everybody was
really strict protocol so yeah um I
couldn't get sick because if I don't go
to work about 200 people don't go to
work so that I'm telling you what that
was so stressful on me like I never got
it like but I was like that was that was
so stressful because it's like so so
many people are going to be out of work
if I get sick and like you can't help it
like you're you're doing all you can
that was a lot of people they don't call
me Grandpa they don't call you Grandpa
no they call me hoppy oh why Hoppy
do you bounce a lot
um when I was born my dad was in the
Army Air Force in World War II and um
he didn't see me till I was two years
old so I lived with my grandparents and
my mom oh
and that was Mimi and hoppy yeah
so when we had kids all of their my dad
and mom's kids we started calling my dad
hoppy so yeah oh so I asked my son Kevin
that the first time
um
they call me grandpa I said could they
call me hoppy yeah you're like that I
love that it's like special to your
family
[Applause]
dinners all the time so do you all do
cast dinners because y'all are around we
do real dinners for about eight hours
um
food gets a little cold yeah yeah
um and um you know and and film work you
you kind of repeat
um what you do is the camera moves
around so whatever you choose to eat at
the beginning you're just gonna have to
re-eat it and re-eat it and re-eat it
continuity but that's fine I'm listen I
love our cast yeah we have a family of
actors as well as a family of of
characters and we all catch up Donnie
and Bridget and will and yeah Lynn and
everybody so about every eight days we
we see each other and uh um it's we have
a good time I know I think it's fun it
shows I think and and it I think it does
too the chemistry especially but it's
funny sometimes I always laugh that I
see my work family more than I see my
actual family sometimes because you know
you're working a lot so yeah especially
with a commute like that
um so Blue Bloods it just did its is it
250th episode that's incredible yeah I
know that's incredible
um how does that feel well I don't know
where the time went but yeah I uh we did
163 hours of Magnum and I thought wow
okay you can't get lucky twice yeah was
uh and really lovely little celebration
it's a blessing to have a show that
everybody loves like that yeah yeah I
got a mortgage yeah
and
anything like you love what you do right
and it's awesome when people reciprocate
that love yeah they love it I keep doing
it and
so far so good I know people are people
are digging it you're a hit
um that's that's crazy and not only just
12 years but your entire career is crazy
that's a it's a remarkable career yeah
the hardest thing is to guest on our
show yeah that's that's true I I try to
relax the new actors because yeah that's
really hard to come on everybody's up to
speed it's like when I did Friends it
was they were up to speed they've read
the you were amazing in friends did you
like doing stick hunting I wasn't
amazing at what they call the table read
who cares better herself show like no
that
that was when Monica's on your voicemail
Breezy and like you are just so great
did you like doing the sitcom I was I
was scared to death I had done a taxi a
long time before but I hadn't done a
sitcom and and and so I was really
nervous and Courtney helped a lot
Courtney's a big help
um but that group is uh it's just a an
incredible group of friends yeah yeah it
was obviously became friends in life
yeah well as on the show and it shows
and it was a wonderful place to work and
we ended up doing about nine of them I
know I watched all of them I was only
supposed to do three I know well that's
how good you are so yeah I was like
people love you I don't know if you know
this
um so America loves a good mustache and
I gotta be honest with you you were I
mean you were Steve Harvey's Ron
Burgundy I love a good mustache I'm
telling you look at these all these
mustache we love a good mustache so be
honest do you actually like because
you're you're affiliated with a mustache
for life regardless you want to know how
do you feel about that do you ever just
want to shave it off
I I was born that way yes
it looks like a solid mustache though
when did that grow in like 15 times
somewhere along the line
one puberty struck I was gonna say it
had to be because that's a thick
mustache yeah before Magnum I worked
most of the time without it I know maybe
I did
yeah I'm just saying but you yeah maybe
that's why you needed
it's just a really great mustache um so
your your look on Magnum PI mustache has
its own names his agents here
yeah I should
that's such a classic look
I just want to see that photo show
everybody again remind you of how good
this looks yeah
there is nothing that's
been sure okay sure that you know that
people love that Magnum PI look so much
but they still dress like you and
actually one of those people works here
and her name is Tegan so here's this
photo
yeah
look at her trying to like pop your
there's Teagan over there
see we love we love the look I love the
mustache thank you I know and when
puberty hits it'll really come it'll
really I'm telling
one I have dated they can't they can't
grow mustaches some people can't Ashton
Kutcher told me he couldn't grow a good
mustache I know he has the bullish look
thing right yeah you've got that
straight up I'm a man like it's not yeah
I'm disappointed that that
you didn't wear the shorts
questions because they're short you know
what though they they were short then
back in the day though
shorts are short they are and and those
pajama bottoms that they wore for about
the last decade yeah are silly and you
can trip on them and they're you know
what are they they're coming back up
they are on some people but on others
that don't have maybe the basketball
players sports are coming back they're
coming out they should be they're coming
I love that you're like into short
shorts this is my this is the most
fabulous thing that will happen to me
today you talking about how we need to
work I cheated you know if I had a you
know I read the script and I knew if I
had a fight scene coming up okay I
wouldn't wear the shorts yeah because I
want to put pads underneath beneath my
jeans and stuff but uh I cheated that
way better but it's it's hot over there
I'm just saying I not everybody can
sport shorts like that well then
well I I played basketball
um
right up until College when I actually
sat on the bench at USC instead of
playing all the time but uh you're not
better about athletes yeah but it didn't
affect my legs it didn't affect they
still look great
the legs and the mustache she got it all
I should have worn sharks too you should
have worn shorts next time if you don't
wear shorts I'm promising you this I
won't be in shorts there is it's a it's
a big over me well either yeah it's like
a little different not pretty anymore
I've always been I've always had a big
butt so like even when I was a kid when
I wear shorts like the short ones it you
can see her butt so that's why I don't
like short shorts because some of us
have a lot of junk in the trunk okay so
it'll look at Lester back there
laughs Lester's like there's nothing
wrong with that ma'am
um thank you so much there's no way to
end that there's no segue from that
thank you so much for being here I'm
such a big fan we love this show every
everybody you can see Blue Bloods
Fridays on CBS
[Music]